Democratic Senator Bernie Sanders, who you
probably know is also running for president.
The 20 is now calling for the House of Representatives
to immediately start an impeachment inquiry
into Donald Trump.
And despite the fact that what he wants is
an impeachment inquiry, there have been a
ton of posts and discussions and comments
online, which initially said Bernie is calling
for Trump's removal.
And that's just not what Bernie did.
Bernie is calling for the removal of Trump
by voting him out in 2020.
That's one way that Bernie Sanders is saying
Donald Trump should be removed, but Bernie
Sanders has only called for the beginning
of an impeachment inquiry.
That's step one in the impeachment process.
Uh, interestingly, this happened at a campaign
rally late last week.
It was not mentioned for days by media outlets.
And when it was initially mentioned, a lot
of the reaction to the story was completely
misunderstanding what it is that Bernie Sanders
said.
So this is the right call that Bernie Sanders
is making.
And Bernie Sanders, like the David Pakman
show like other shows, we all realize that
the Republican Senate is not going to convict
Donald Trump and actually remove him from
office.
But the fact support starting an impeachment
inquiry period.
And that's why I'm glad Bernie's doing this.
He said at this rally in Henderson, Nevada,
uh, quote, I believe the House Judiciary Committee
should begin impeachment inquiries.
That is inquiries not impeachment to determine
whether or not Trump has committed impeachable
offenses.
This is an important change, not because Bernie
saying it will make impeachment more of a
reality more quickly, but because it's starting
to become a distraction, does burning not
think there should be an impeachment inquiry?
What's wrong with Bernie?
Why isn't Bernie willing to say it?
Well now Bernie Sanders has made it clear
that he supports an impeachment inquiry, but
I've got to make the same statement again
that I've been saying for awhile and impeachment
inquiry is not impeachment and impeachment
is not removal.
Okay?
The process is inquiry during which there
is testimony, investigation, debate by the
house.
If they determine that impeachment articles
should be filed, those articles are then filed
by the house.
They require a majority simple majority, 50%
plus one of the four and 35 house members.
Then there is a trial of sorts that the house
puts forward.
All of the evidence they believe supports
the impeachment of the president, at which
point the Senate votes on whether to convict
and remove the president or not.
Uh, and to convict, you need two thirds of
the Senate.
All we're talking about here, all that Bernie
Sanders is talking about is an impeachment
inquiry.
So there are a whole bunch of wrong reactions
to this news.
The first wrong reaction to this news is that,
uh, many have said, oh, Bernie's calling for
the removal of Trump.
But that's not what he's doing.
It's just not.
It's wrong in two ways.
Number one, Bernie's just calling for the
inquiry, which happens before impeachment
articles or even filed.
And number two, even impeachment by the house
wouldn't remove Trump.
Only a conviction by the Senate would remove
Trump and it's not gonna happen.
Okay?
That's not the point.
The point is we want to expose what Trump
has done and potentially we can him in 2020
there are others who are reacting to this
saying, Bernie, so weak, he's riding the fence.
He's only calling for an inquiry.
He should just buckle down and call for impeachment.
It's a silly criticism.
Bernie's a senator.
Bernie would conceivably be one of the people
voting on the trial that would be brought
forth by these articles of impeachment.
If they were ever filed, it would be in a
sense inappropriate for Bernie to say, now
we must remove Trump.
What most senators have been saying, uh, is
that they believe either an inquiry should
start or that the house should file articles.
Uh, and then later the Senate would ultimately
be making the decision about how do they want
to vote and do they get that two thirds support.
So Bernie is 100% correct here.
He's saying do the inquiry.
That's the required first step.
It's great news.
Maybe it will put more pressure on people
like Nancy Pelosi who have been sort of hesitant
to consider impeachment.
Uh, and Bernie Sanders is, you know, some
people will criticize him for this, but I
believe that, uh, the net positive benefit
of him just saying this and getting it out
of the way, make sense.
I'm glad he did it.
I agree.
Let's start that inquiry as soon as humanly
possible.